now jobless claims shattering another
record that's not a record you want to
shatter for the second week in a row the
number of Americans filing for
unemployment benefits spiked to 6.6
million people that's more than 10
million jobs lost in two weeks it is
horrific and it's demoralizing and their
real lives and real people behind every
statistic but my next guest says America
has the ability to come out of this
stronger than ever before joining me now
is Mark Cuban entrepreneur and star of
the show shark tank
all right mark first of all I'm a
massive fan of shark tank don't you we
need shark tank we need shark tank
thinking right now but how people are
really down I've got to tell you like
I'm getting emails people are so down
for a whole bunch of reasons but a lot
of them related to not being able to go
to work or their children go to schools
what needs to happen coming out of this
you know we're going to go through a
reset I don't know when we're gonna get
from America 1.0 to America 2.0 but
we'll get there and what needs to happen
is we have to realize that we are the
most entrepreneurial country in the
world that were a country full of people
who are going to start start businesses
and that's what's going to lead us
through all of this somebody has a
vision out there of what we're gonna
look like on the other side and when we
look back in five years we're gonna
realize that there are five or ten or
twenty five amazing companies that were
started that just changed the world and
led us through all this to a brighter
future of course mark what a lot of
folks are talking about is our reliance
on China for basic necessities things
like generic drugs a lot of these just
anti-inflammatories a lot of the
supplies that we don't have we have to
go you know beg you begging and scraping
and bowing to a communist country that
subjugates its own people and lies about
a disease to be able to get our own
stuff like what has to happen on that
basic level so there's two questions
there one is what do we do in general
because we're seeing a lot of our
supplies for PPE not being available and
that's being dependent on manufacturers
you
China and around the world the first
thing we need to do is start investing
in the future of manufacturing not try
to recreate what we did in the past but
looking towards robotics and software
and automation in AI in such a way that
we can just dominate that area you know
a lot of people are concerned that if we
don't do it the old way and have
manufacturing lines and we won't have
enough employment but there's so much
intellectual capacity here that I think
really we can take robotics to a level
where we bring back almost all that
manufacturing and create a surplus of
jobs but we have to focus on that and
when we look at an infrastructure bill I
truly believe it's got to be
infrastructure 2.0 where we focus not
just on redoing streets and roads and
bridges but focus on robotics and future
technologies so we can define and take
over in the future and that means that
American companies mark does it not
they asked have to think patriotically
too and people people hear the word
nationalism they think oh that's scary
I get what they're saying but this is
just we need to hear if we don't heal
ourselves we're not gonna be worth
anything to help other people because
people are gonna say to heck with this
I'm not I'm not gonna worry about any
country or their country or Wars we're
not gonna fund the military until my kid
can learn to do robotics in school
they're not gonna want to do anything so
what about that aspect of it this is
just good old-fashioned capitalism with
some support from the government
you know we invested in NASA we wanted
to go to the moon you know the president
wants to go to Mars when it cutting you
we invest at the NIH National Institute
of Health
most of the single molecule drugs that
come out of there lead to the biggest
discoveries that our pharmacy companies
have it's not unusual for us to invest
in technology to lead the way in the
world and that's what we have to do you
lude it to drugs most of our drugs come
from China in India they're not well
conceived and we have to take that back
over but this again this is what
capitalism is all about and this is why
I know we can make it work and mark what
are you doing for your many many
employees during this difficult time I
know they all employ people you know I'm
lucky enough that not have as many of
you to worry about them yeah
keeping my employees on you just have to
if you can after and good for you Laura
I mean you with the Mavericks even
though the NBA seasons been suspended we
continue to pay them as if we're
continuing to play I have a restaurant
in LA we're paying the barbacks the
bartenders the waiters the waitresses
everybody as if we were still open and
we're doing that for our other companies
as well for those people who can afford
it it's just the right thing to do and
do you think this stimulus a lot of
people are calling me up saying I know
they had to do something but it's not
getting to the small businesses the
businesses that don't make that 500
person cap they're worried about being
able to pay their rent pay their you
know commercial real estate you know
loans and so forth are you worried about
that no I actually I thought it was a
great move I give the administration a
lot of credit you know if you own a
small business with under five hundred
employees or even if you own a
franchisee that's part of a larger
organization with more than 500 you need
to go right to sba.gov right now and
then go to your bank at midnight because
that's when it opens up and so any
company with under 500 employees the
government will pay your payroll for the
next three months and if you don't fire
anybody and possibly hire people you
don't have to pay it back that's the
best that's the best deal ever offered
in the history of business alright mark
it's great to see you come back soon
okay I hope so thanks Lori thanks for
hanging there